[Música]
bueno hoy realmente a diferencia de
muchas charlas que he realizado estoy un
poquito más nervioso de lo normal porque
estoy aquí en la tadeo que es mi alma
máter aunque no me gradué
estoy nervioso porque pues me sugirieron
a hablar de un tema que es un poco
diferente para mí me sugirió en cambiar
el tema que siempre hablo que sobre la
pasión y dije como bueno pues voy a
arriesgarme voy a intentarlo y voy a
hablar de algo diferente realmente voy a
hablar sobre el origen de mi pasión que
es el graffiti
mientras mucha gente a mis 13 años
empezaban a creerse ronaldinho en el
parque jugando fútbol yo a diferencia de
ellos disfrutar de otro tipo de cosas
este soy yo un poquito diferente más
rapero
yo disfrutado otro tipo de cosas yo
disfrutaba de caminar por los caños de
bogotá de ese increíble aroma que tienen
los caños de bogotá pintar los caños de
bogotá al son de un buen tema de rap
mientras iba caminando por ellos y
mientras los iba pintando lo que me
gustaba en ese momento era pintar los
caños de bogotá
algo un poco extraño en la época de mi
colegio que es una época que recuerdo
mucho
y me pasa algo muy particular mientras
yo llegaba con mi maleta todo feliz mis
amigos llegaban con sus maletas y toda
pesada yo me preguntaba por qué lleva
esa maleta todo pensando así todo feliz
pues ellos llevaban el álgebra de baldor
una maleta llena de libros pesada y yo
en cambio de llevar el álgebra bardo ya
mis pinturitas marcadores y algo que era
muy importante para mí en esa época era
un libro sobre la historia del grafiti
para mí eso era súper importante
yo recuerdo que en esa época yo no era
muy bueno con los números bueno todavía
no soy muy bueno con los números en
realidad pero lo chistoso de esto es que
mis papás son profesores de matemáticas
entonces era un poco raro eso pero mis
profesores se dieron cuenta de eso y en
vez de ponerme a hacer exámenes de
álgebra física y todo esto
pusieron la tarea de bueno pues porque
no me pinta el mural citó con el paisaje
en el colegio hacer las carteleras de
los eventos culturales y realmente así
fue que yo pasé el colegio y me puede
grabar
yo recuerdo mucho ese momento de mi vida
porque fue cuando realmente encontré mi
pasión lo que más me gustaba hacer en la
vida
hacer graffiti ilegal pintar en la calle
me encantaba poner mi nombre por todas
partes ponía 000 hacia esas firmas
bandas las que todo el mundo no le
gustan
y yo perseguía ese sueño todo el tiempo
todos los días iba detrás de ese sueño
era lo que más me gustaba perseguía ese
sueño día
día a día y noche sobre todo en las
noches era algo pues más clandestino en
esa época empezábamos a hacer algo que
se llamaba o lo llamábamos las rutas del
graffiti o algo así como bombín
realmente clásicamente se llama bombín
esto era un poco no sé a mí me gustaba
mucho empezar esto poniendo música rap
era como un ritual para mí voy a música
rap ponía algunos vídeos de graffiti
para ir calentando para ir amenizando la
noche y empezaba a empacar para ya las 2
y media de la mañana empezar a empacar
toda mi pintura en unas bolsas de basura
negras por lo general llevamos 22 bolsas
de basura negra para salir a pintar y
aparte de eso pues obviamente nos
vestíamos de acuerdo a la ocasión
ropa para eso por lo general es la negra
para camuflarlos en la noche o pues una
técnica que a veces algunos hacíamos era
aparecer habitantes de calle para que la
policía no nos cogiera
nosotros empezábamos a pintar por lo
general yo pintaba más que todo en el
norte entonces empezamos en el norte de
la ciudad hasta el sur de la ciudad
empezamos a caminar cogíamos todas las
avenidas principales pues porque para
nosotros era lo más lógico si cogemos
las avenidas principales
al otro día todo el mundo que sale en su
transmilenio en su carrito pues va a ver
todo lo que pintamos digamos que eso era
lo que más nos gustaba a nosotros y era
que todo el mundo pudiera ver lo que
pintamos en ese momento
entonces cuando yo me acercaba a la
calle a la noche la adrenalina y todo
esto era lo que me hacía hablar con la
ciudad realmente me sentía parte de ella
yo en esa época cuando todavía viva en
un barrio al norte de la ciudad que es
el barrio cedritos un barrio de clase
media
y en esa época a diferencia de ahorita
no nos conocíamos los artistas de
graffiti o los grafiteros como lo
quieran llamar por facebook o por
instagram sino realmente nos poníamos en
la tarea de pintar toda la calle
hacíamos tados nos tiramos todas las
paredes
y bueno así era la manera de conocernos
por lo general cuando uno veía como
muchas firmas bueno les voy a decir un
secreto cuando no hay muchas firmas de
alguien en un mismo lugar por lo general
vive ahí
pues para que lo vayan a denunciar así
sí no
pero era lo que pasaba era la manera de
conocernos una vez yo actor ahí
caminando y villamán en una bicicleta
pintando una firma que yo había mucho
por mi casa y yo me acerqué como ella y
usted que está haciendo no sé por qué no
se asustó yo me era asustado ya no salió
a correr pero él me dijo que como no no
estoy aquí pintando estoy haciendo un
graffiti y el heavy yo también hago eso
en ese momento
raro ver a la gente pintando de día
entonces yo me le acerqué él me dijo no
yo hago graffiti le dije ah pero ustedes
por acá y él me dijo como no realmente
yo vivo en ciudad bolívar en el sur de
bogotá yo que es súper impresionado
porque pues el más me tenía el barrio
todo pintado lo pintaba más que yo y yo
era como sistema en que entonces
hablando con el man descubrí que el man
era el que hacía los domicilios en el
barrio claro obviamente el más en
bicicleta y todo el tiempo veía todo el
barrio pintado nos volvimos muy muy
amigos
y más adelante empezamos a pintar mucho
en el sur de bogotá así fue que yo
conocí el sur de bogotá gracias a él
gracias a esa persona conocí que era
pintar en el sur de bogotá que pues era
un poquito más caliente que pintar en el
norte ottavia mente en una de esas medio
por eso yo hablando con la policía
el gasto medio por pintar les la
estación de policía unos policías porque
lo hice no tengo ni ideas yo creo que la
adrenalina a las ganancias era algo
loquísimo entonces ya que tuvo un tinte
de la estación de policía y obviamente
la gente de la gente el señor agente me
cogió y me pegó un poquito sólo un
poquito vamos a decir que sólo un
poquito de mis pinturas se las
llevó y tiró todos mis papeles por la
calle en esa época lo normal era o bueno
todavía es que lo suban a un camión el
camión de la pj y lo trasladen por toda
la ciudad
entonces me subieron al camión de la pj
que yo creo que algunos usted lo conoce
por ahí
me subieron y me pusieron a compartir
con todo tipo de personas
conocí ladrones habitantes de calle
el problema que hayan cogido por estar
orinando ahí en la calle y todas estas
personas tenían historias increíbles
gracias a esto gracias a que duraba toda
la noche hablando con ellos y contándome
sus historias yo contándole las mías
ellos decían ay usted apartamenteros y
yo no no señor yo estaba pintando
grafitis gracias a esto fue que yo me
volví parte de la calle el graffiti
digamos que me permitió ver el mundo de
una manera diferente para mí ya no
existía el norte el sur los ricos los
pobres sino el mundo en general y todo
esto me hizo conocer amigos de
diferentes tipos de estratos sociales
todo gracias al graffiti
después de todo esto
crecí un poco pues en edad
no crezco más creció un poco y entré
aquí a la universidad a la tarea la
grandiosa jorge tadeo lozano
y pensé que me iba a enamorar del
estudio como todos los que pueden estar
aquí en el estudio pero no realmente lo
que pasó pues fue que me desespera un
poco porque entré a la universidad
empecé a ver clases de diseño y cómo que
tuve un conflicto en cuanto al diseño el
graffiti la fiesta y me confundió un
poco y entré en desesperación ya me
gustaba lo que hacía no me gustaba lo
que pintaba
y gracias a esto pues bueno gracias a
eso fue algo muy triste dejé el graffiti
más o menos por un año
digamos que esto fue algo que realmente
me metió como en un hueco muy oscuro era
como una etapa oscura de mi vida
alegre entonces
yo me pusiera a reflexionar mucho
mientras estaba en la universidad y
mientras una profesora está dando una
clase de diseño que creo que no está por
ahí espero que
ella hablaba y hablaba yo ahí en mi
cuadernito dibujando dibujando y
realmente yo sólo pensaba en pintar
graffiti y en pintar graffiti y me di
cuenta que la calle otra vez me estaba
llamando y dije como bueno pues por qué
no intentar hacer otras cosas pues ya
que estoy aquí en la universidad y
aplicarlas en la calle entonces traté de
empezar a pintar graffiti con un
propósito o de otra manera y empecé a
experimentar este tipo de cosas empecé a
vincular lo que sabía de la calle y
empezar a mezclarlo con el diseño
gráfico con la ilustración
y llegó un momento de mi vida en el que
también allí en la universidad me metí
un poco en el movimiento social el
momento estudiantil y me volvió un
poquito un poquito más abierto puedo
aceptarlo era un poquito más abierto y
entonces dije como bueno porque no
aplicó esto también al graffiti y empecé
a pintar consignas estudiantiles
consignas de protesta en la calle como
esta de cero represión o quién me cuida
de los que me cuidan y yo creía que esa
era la manera en la que realmente podía
impactar a la gente que yo creía que la
gente iba a decir como busqué chimbas el
graffiti me está diciendo algo pero una
vez más la calle me abrió los ojos y eso
fue con este mural
yo pinté este mural con muchas ganas y
con muchas expectativas de que no pues
realmente la gente que iba a pasar por
ahí iba a tomar conciencia de un montón
de cosas porque porque es donde lo pinte
vivían
habitantes de calle dormían ahí cuando
lo termine de pintar resulta que llega
un habitante calle se levanta lo mira y
me dice
pero usted que va a saber de la pobreza
hago milito de
y yo hay que sanz que callado no sabía
qué decirle en parte él tenía razón pero
no porque yo no supiera la pobreza no
hubiera tenido contacto con ella sino
porque realmente ahí yo entendí una cosa
y era que esa era su casa ese era su
hogar y yo estaba pintando una vaina que
para él pues no tenía sentido
desde ese momento fue que deje de soñar
con pintar mi nombre por todas partes y
hacer cosas tan ego científicas como
pintar 0000 y empecé a pintar cosas o a
pensar en querer pintar cosas por y para
los demás eso cambió un poco mi vida
pero realmente obviamente no pasó
después de que el habitante de calle
mejores yo empecé a hacer otro tipo de
cosas seguí haciendo graffiti este
estilo de graffiti graffiti hip hop
letras enredadas y empecé también a
conocer a estos artistas que me dejaron
o me enseñaron de pronto a atreverme a
ilustrar en la calle
estos fueron como mis primeros
acercamientos a la ilustración o al
muralismo que digamos que aquí es como
lo que la gente conoce un poco de lo que
yo estoy haciendo
aquí en la tarde del museo
paso el tiempo pasó mucho tiempo
obviamente desde ahí pasaron muchas
cosas mientras yo estaba pintando
hasta que llegue a esto un proyecto
social un proyecto muy bonito que se
llama mil colores para mi pueblo es un
proyecto que por medio de el arte nos
conectamos con la comunidad
a una comunidad que realmente ha sido
afectada por la violencia por el
conflicto armado y la excusa del arte es
esa conectarnos con ellos yo llegué a
este pueblo que se llamaba el paraíso
desde el nombre yo ya me enamoré de un
pueblo que se llama el paraíso yo ya me
lo imaginaba así
para llegar allá toca va a llegar en esa
chiva que en ustedes ahí era un poco
complicado con este proyecto con los
lugares que la mayoría de nosotros no
conocemos y eso es lo más bonito este
proyecto llegó así por por las chivas
tun tun tun subiendo una montaña y de
repente vi una casa que me gustó
muchísimo dije ahí quiero pintar
entonces el director mejor le tranquilo
pinten si es lo que quiere tal por lo
general yo no improviso cuando estoy
pintando murales pero en este proyecto
era necesario porque uno tiene que
hablar con la comunidad y realmente
trabajar de la mano con ellos yo me paré
de frente a esta pared y no se llegó la
inspiración así po de la nada y empecé a
pintar esto es un personaje que va sobre
una sombrilla en un lago acompañado de
su amigo el pececito que va por ahí
yo lo veía muy bonito pero lo que pasó
después fue aún más bonito llegó esta
señora la que está ahí sentada
y se me acerco con sus ojos casi
llorosos
y me dijo muchas gracias jóvenes yo le
dije como
pero porque ya mejor no es que usted no
sabe lo que significa para mí este mural
y empezó a contarme una historia que
realmente fue muy impactante para mí
me contó que ella vivía en el pueblo de
abajo y hace un año una avalancha se
había llevado toda su casa y alcanzaba a
recuperar algunas cosas pero no todo y
este era su nuevo hogar y yo estaba
pintando le aparte de que a ella le
parecía algo muy bonito le parecía algo
muy significativo ella me dijo cómo se
está contando ahí mi historia en su
mural sin haberme conocido yo quedé
realmente muy sorprendido después de
esto aparte de todo me dijo como aquí en
el pueblo nos dicen los pescaditos
ahí fue cuando me di cuenta que sin
querer algo de mi imaginación se
convirtió en realidad fue algo que
realmente fue muy impactante para mí y
gracias a este proyecto fue que dije
bueno voy a empezar un nuevo propósito
en mis murales pasó mucho tiempo hasta
este momento
y empecé a hacer otro tipo de cosas
pasaron muchos años también y entendí
como el significado de trabajar en
equipo y medio por algo que
qué es un poco difícil es emprender y
empecé me estudio que se llama a tres
manos estudio que está conformado por
muy relevante que la chica que ven ahí y
por demos los tres venimos de esa
escuela que les conté al principio de
pintar cosas ilegales y así fue que nos
conocimos nos volvimos muy amigos
y gracias a esto fue que decidimos con
la misma edición que todos teníamos
empezar a hacer murales de gran formato
empezar a contar historias mágicas a
través de colores texturas personajes
y realmente esto fue muy muy bonito para
mí todo lo que viví desde pequeño había
llegado hasta este momento
nada esto haya sido posible ni había
sido tan fácil
y la verdad sufrí mucho digamos en esto
emprender pero así como con esta charla
que tuve muchos problemas al empezar y
realmente no sabía qué camino
volví a lo que siempre me gusta al
origen a lo que soy yo a mi esencia que
es el graffiti que es la calle
mi herramienta siempre fue la pintura el
graffiti me hizo crecer y gracias al
graffiti fue que empecé a soñar ya
construir mis sueños a pintar mis sueños
ahora yo les hago una pregunta muy
grande a todos ustedes cuando va a
esperar cuánto van a esperar para
empezar a contar sus propios sueños
[Música]